LISA WRAY: Hi, I'm Lisa Wray.
Welcome back to the Google
Fit APIs for Android.
So in my last
DevByte, I promised
to show you how to
write a fitness app that
saves and retrieves user
data without a database
and without our own back end.
So in that video, I
showed how to set up
an app to use the
Fit APIs and how
to receive sensor data to
play a real time step count.
If you haven't
watched it already,
you should probably go see it
now before watching this one.
The next step for our app is
to save the user's step data
so they can look at
their records later,
and this is where the
recording API comes in.
The recording API
provides automated storage
of fitness data
using subscriptions.
Google Fit stores
the fitness data
that you choose
in the background
and it persists
app subscriptions.
Just like for the
sensor API, we need
to go through all the steps
of connecting to Google Play
services and requesting
the fitness API in scopes.
So we get onconnected,
we're good to go.
The call to subscribe should
look fairly familiar by now.
The difference is which
API we're calling.
Subscribing to the
recording API doesn't
mean we will get call backs to
a listener like the sensor API.
In fact, you may notice there's
no listener involved here
at all.
Instead it means
that Google Fit will
start recording data
in the background
and syncing it with the
Cloud Datastore, all
without any extra work from us.
When we want it later,
we'll go retrieve it.
At the end of the
day, the user probably
wants to see how her day stacked
up against previous ones,
so we'll use the history API
to retrieve the data that Fit
has been storing for us.
The history API provides
access to the fitness history
and lets apps insert, delete,
and read fitness data.
Apps can also import batch
data into Google Fit.
First you need a start and
end for the range of time
where you want to retrieve data.
So let's say we're looking
at data from the last week.
We're asking for the user's
step count bucketed by day.
We want to know how much
they walked each day
and within the last week.
Finally, we'll invoke
the history API
using read data and our request.
In a lot of cases, like
subscribing to a sensor
or adding a listener, the
result comes back instantly,
so we can wait for the
results synchronously.
But it's not the case here.
Fit might need
network communication
to grab results from
the Cloud Datastore.
So we set a result callback,
and we wait for the results
to be delivered asynchronously.
Because we asked to
aggregate by days,
our data result will
contain buckets.
In this case, each bucket
corresponds to one day.
Each bucket has a data set
containing data points.
Here's an example of
iterating through data points
and printing out their
information, like the start
and end times and the
field value pairs.
In our case, each
bucket will have
one data set with one data
point showing the aggregate step
count for that day.
So our app could
graph these to show
how the user's daily step
count changes over time.
So now we're done.
Our app shows step count,
records steps, and can retrieve
fitness data, all
done in our app
using the Fit APIs for Android.
This has been just an example
of what the Fit APIs can do.
Workout sessions, custom
activities, and using
intends to launch
other apps to show
fitness data are just
a few possibilities.
The full API details
are on our website,
but I'd start with
the Fit samples
so you can get up and
running right away.
Thanks for watching,
and I can't wait
to see what you build
with Google Fit.